il ne s'agira pas
d'une guerre 2 0
ce qui veut dire que ça va être amusant
le monde brûle
vous n'avez pas idée de ce dont les
hommes sont capables
nous devons intervenir
je comprends que vous ayez envie de vous
battre
les idées à d'autres façons d'accomplir
votre devoir il va vous falloir un
costume suivez moi nous sommes la
première agence de renseignement
indépendante maintenir la paix et
protéger la vie et à venir
[Musique]
massé
pendant que les gouvernements attendent
des ordres nous passons à l'action
il est temps à présent de montrer au
monde entier
l'ampleur de sa puissance
tiens
[Musique]
josé me
ce que nous sommes
mais la réputation c'est ce que les gens
pensent de vous
le caractère c'est ce que vous allez
vite
armés et prêts
ar mais oui
mais après on va voir ça
ceux ci
s'appelle un parachute ça permet de
sauter d'un aéroplane sans se blesser
[Musique]